Let's look at some of
the new responsibilities you'll have
as the founder of your company.
In an early stage startup,
you'll wear many hats.
You may be the product manager, sales
associate, accountant or something else.
As you grow, you'll give some of these
responsibilities to other people
like co-founders, employees,
freelancers or outsourcing companies.
During this time you're responsible for
providing resources to your team.
This will help them continue
building the service users love.
To do this effectively, you'll need
to provide both the emotional and
physical support your team needs.
So what types of emotional
support should you provide?
Emotionally, you should be able to
communicate what is needed to achieve
your vision and overcome obstacles
by making the important decisions.
You'll also want to make sure they
feel supported, encouraged, and
capable of doing their job correctly.
And what are some of
the physical needs of your team?
They need a place to work from,
even if it's their home.
They need to get paid.
So you'll need some money and
they need equipment like laptops and
infrastructure like servers.
You can ask your team to use their own
equipment will try getting some of
what you need for
free which you could get from many
of the existing start up programs.
Moving forward, try to consider how you
plan to provide these resources for
your team as you continue to grow and
expand your business.
You might need to get creative here, but
take some time to think about what you
can do to give the emotional and
physical support your team needs.